hi my name is Elizabeth South I'm a
private investigator with cane
Associates investigations today I have
been told there are two people in this
lineup who have dated I'm gonna try to
figure out who it is and see if there's
any chemistry left maybe they can
rekindle my interrogation skills are
really good given the circumstances it's
not a typical interrogation obviously so
we'll see on the spot how I could do
with this let's get into the questioning
I'll still start over here you to come
up here what a cute couple
have you guys ever done this before walk
together before few times pass you
always let him take a look like that
sometimes are you just quiet yeah
sometime you just submissive when it
comes to relationships just like you can
do the talking
I once am submissive enough no but she's
like she's very lenient you see what you
love tell me about how you guys met so
we met at the office he was really good
at design and so I asked him to design
one of my photos for me to like clean it
up make it look pretty for like a
thumbnail and he'd do a really good job
because I would have thought he would
have said no sweetie
you really don't need any touch-up so
I'm gonna move this hair over here
you're beautiful it's a good point but
actually the thumbs were enough for me
they're like things that I made of
someone else for a video so tell me
about the break guys this was about
maybe six months ago
no go ahead okay about three months ago
about six months ago in the past we had
hit it off just right by me six months
ago just in a workspace it's not really
professional and like we were like
vibing as much so we can just came the
agreement just to keep it a friendship
yeah I mean it's better to keep it
professionally no because we work
together all right well you lenient to
go ahead and step up there I'm gonna
take these next two obviously you're
nervous about something you have
something to hide you're wearing
sunglasses I don't know dating is like
really the word we like hooked up a
couple of times he split into my insta
diems and then
did you guys practice this earlier no
why would we practice Oh whatever that's
why the did you have sense I just said
hi that's all I'm just so you're
original and not very charming on diems
hi I mean I said more than hi because we
want to get into that I sent her a
picture of a hamburger and she got real
mad at me
your voice is quivering it's not
surprising that - laughs you guys are
obviously very in love and this was
heartbreaking the hamburger was like the
breaking point wasn't just that was
blame she thought that I was being
insensitive oh she's one of those vegans
I'm not it felt like an aggressive
hamburger you know if you guys didn't
date though I do want to say this you
should consider it because I sent some
chemistry here so either it was there
and it's still there and you're not
honest about it for one of you well you
guys hooked up maybe there's chemistry
but not that I want to see you for a
long period of time text messages come
on it wasn't like a serious thing so it
wasn't like I really wasn't it was like
the work on Monday you and your
sunglasses can go up there need a little
crocodile tears the moral you can stand
up there - okay thank you sweetie yeah
all right you two come down here if you
two were together you either hate each
other you have terrible chemistry y'all
like stand this for our part why you
don't even pull her seed out of a
breakup
kinda like them casual thing so it
wasn't really much of a big or bad
breakup he was one of those people where
I realized that like okay I can't do
this casual stuff anymore I think it was
romanticized
it was a short thing when romantics have
a sense that's what I thought he is very
genuine eyes he could be romantic and
tell you something unexpected exactly
okay okay so what first attracted you I
mean pretty much everything you just
said
look at those eyeballs they're huge and
blue well having that's kind of weird um
I was actually dating someone else at
the time he was at this party and we
kind of were flirting and again a casual
things move like Condren how did you
guys meet tell me about your interaction
I was alone and you know I'm kind of a
natural flirt so I saw a cute girl
standing by the drinks and I was just
like sure let's go talk to her
I see what's up leichter and got to know
her didn't realize she had boyfriends
and then she actually reached out to me
a week later how'd she reach out to he
texted you should got the number from a
friend would you text him I get coffee
get coffee where'd you guys have coffee
go spells where cousin was it close yeah
yeah there's one in Hollywood right
that's where we had is legit angels it
was very memorable for you which fills
it was out by the way yes
oh my favorite coffee the problem was
like you know two three months
relationships what if you guys dated I
okay I need to go take a shower cuz that
just hurt me even stand up I may bring
you guys back for some other people
could I have you down here and then can
I have you back here alright so how'd
you guys meet oh here okay stand back up
alright so how was the break-up all
right how did you meet actually not just
how you broke up that was kind of mean
to go straight to that we also met at a
party through a mutual friend and then
just started talking and yeah stayed in
touch
where's the party yet beverlywood I'm
new here so I still got to kind of get
the you know there is where's he from
he's also from New York okay
let me see you haven't I gotten okay why
don't we roll you and you come sit down
yeah you look like I don't know so I'm
gonna get their hair done she buys new
vans five pairs of really after the
breakup it's not because the break-up it
happened to happen after mm-hmm the
break-up okay
Merl so how did you guys meet hinge
Becca
I don't think I've had you and you
together
alright what's his name Mitch Mitchell
what's her name Emily what's his last
name
self Phaedra what's her last she always
watches my last name always
trio mmm how long have you guys known
each other a couple months is that upset
you when she's answering questions a
little bit I mean the breakup was kind
of a try to say it without smiling
Bonnie convinced me a little bit right
now all right so how'd you guys meet how
did we meet well okay they're bad you
guys go ahead you and you together down
here what's her name Nick
her name's Nick your name her name's Liz
Liz all right and what's his name Nick
last name cool well if you guys know
stuff that must have been very low
speaking running nobody nobody can
pronounce so why don't you try to
convince me and tell me about how you
guys met so hinge okay that unhinge
actually message him first and we
started talking he asked me on a date
the first date which is drinks and we
bandied around a couple different ideas
wound up going to Isabel Fairfax what
did you sit in Isabel there's like a
table in the back and the bed I'll be
sad yeah okay so when you go and you go
right left her backs I'm pretty familiar
with Isabel went in just straight ahead
okay yeah straight ahead all the way to
the back
I got a great fruity type drink tell me
about the patio outside it's really dark
and it's cool because there's like trees
on the inside but not on the outside
there's like it's really cushy chairs
that are also really nice and they're
like leather and then on the inside it's
white chairs and tell me about the
bathroom the bathroom mm-hmm the
bathroom was it's pretty memory nice but
a tile floor I think oh great okay let's
see have I had everyone else down here
yeah yeah I need you with her go ahead
and stand up so how'd you guys meet mark
I moved to this office from the New York
office
she didn't the one that's really popular
everyone what's your favorite thing
about her what was your favorite thing
about her that attracted like a
personality thing or a physical thing
well if you guys had no joy that long
and it didn't last that long how'd you
get two months long enough it's really
like six times seven times we hung out a
lot yeah it was a lot a lot for a while
okay
she lives in West Hollywood - I actually
do live in West Hollywood
I forget oh that is so interesting you
forget where you live Santa Monica all
right okay you guys definitely are not
together
all right sit down here fine switch it
out well I see you guys accuse maybe you
are all right what does he live he was
almost foolish I used to yeah I live my
pants on is that what broke you guys his
parents he moved in with his parents
their parents didn't like her idea I'm
here cuz she posted something about like
vegan food on her story and I've always
wanted to try like like trying to be
vegan for a little bit so I just wanted
to see like I cut with the life-sized
and if it really is expensive as people
say it is people ask me all the time
about like vegan recipes and stuff well
I feel like that's a really good move if
that's what happened because you know
somebody would be think it's really cute
they're interested in something other
than better than hi it wasn't or diems
what'd you say uh I forgot what she
posted but I was like oh I'm like I've
always wanted to try like something
vegan like what is it that you're making
whenever something ions as well go I
don't remember this is from this
restaurant honey bee is like this new
vegan place and most feel is I also love
almost feels not West Hollywood they
have the impossible double patty burger
there and I posted a photo did you make
that and I was like no you can't buy the
impossible ready but you can my can't
you can buy the beyond burger but the
impossible patty you can only get a
restaurants where'd you go on your date
we went to a park and had some lunch a
little picnic type of thing Oh picnic
she I pack I packed
beef which kind of set
not wrong come on you have to do better
than that on what I don't know didn't SP
sure I wasn't gonna be you never get to
me to be and especially if you DM her oh
I'll bring beef she packed it okay you
guys your story stock alright alright
back up have I had you I've had you with
all the girls no you haven't
okay come sit down here have me about
your love story music festival music I
was cold lightning in a bottle and they
had like every type of music I love
lightning in a battle really work so
how'd you guys meet there we actually
went down together cuz we're helping
each other with videos I actually had
not met her before you're just always
like yeah and that's right well okay
tell me about it so she was helping me
film a video and so that's kind of how
we started to get to know each other but
then we had like the last day free to
like actually experience the festival
and that's how we castrate yeah yeah I
believe that you guys actually did go to
a music festival together okay you do
kind of look sad right now though now
I'm gonna guilty how did you break up we
just kind of talked about it in person
and tomorrow explained to me that like
you know she's newly single and she like
wants to explore that and like didn't
want anything serious and like we had
the strong connection so we didn't want
to like continue it because I'm looking
for something more serious and she's
like not really there yet so if this is
a lie like I'm feeling really emotional
I feel like it's these girls right now
these girls feel like right now so
genuine and if they're not then like I
give up maybe I should just stop P I
work if you guys weren't the ones
together
yeah maybe I'm stupid but I'm ready to
stop I feel like I know who it is I feel
like the investigation went really well
I caught a lot of people for sure who
were lying I feel pretty confident about
my choice of people who are dating or
who who used to date Merlin Liz would
you please step forward
were you two ever dating no very good
friends oh my god that was all real like
the things you did cuz I was like no
this is all real okay
really that is you too
we did good at Isabel yeah you know and
you don't even mention the stairs
outside Isabel the bathroom all the
great photo doesn't even know what food
you have a great fruity drink that was
cheap shot so you didn't tell me the
truth yeah they're supposed to tell me
the real story this was it seriously
this is no no no if you're gonna play
the game you got to tell me the real
story you can't lie about somebody and
the things you didn't do with them so
that was messed up now okay there is
some chemistry over here I just want you
guys to know but you guys you guys are
really seem like really good friends and
I could have believed that you guys
totally hooked up
[Music]